yourself
I know a lot of you that are watching
Big entrances so here's a gift for you
today I'm going to be featuring some of
my favorite entrances from action anime
these past three years I'll talk about
them and I do hope that they'll serve as
a reminder to What epic three years
we've had so far the best news is that
the decade is still young and we still
have a lot to look forward to but a
brief look at the past to get those
memories back and those Goosebumps
Rising again won't be bad at all will it
right but before that I'd like to give a
shout out to the sponsors of this video
honkai star rail honkai star rail is an
all-new free to play strategy RPG title
in the Hawkeye series that continues the
spiritual core of the resistance and
coexistence of humans and Destiny the
makers of genshin impact hoyovers have
outdone themselves with this game the
character art design is simply Exquisite
with dozens of characters to choose from
each with their own unique Flair be sure
to find a style that suits you plus you
can develop their abilities to fight and
create a formidable team to embark on a
wondrous Interstellar journey together
now one of the things I love about this
game is the story it really is
compelling you'll step onto the
interstellar astral Express and meet new
acquaintances each with their own
backstory and the cutscenes are
top-notch with professional
cinematography and animation direction
that gives you the same level experience
as a top-notch anime or TV series with a
star-studded voice cast and availability
in four languages you'll feel fully
immersed in this Rich World trust me you
don't want to miss out on this one check
the link in the description to join the
Trailblazers and embark on your own
Interstellar journey in honkai's Star
rail today first off we have one from
ushoku tensei
[Music]
it's been a hot while since I talked
about mushoko tensei right it's
definitely a contender for anime of the
year when it first aired and it owes
that distinction to its great adaptation
and moments like these early on are the
ones that help prove the point what a
way to make a first impression for
Guillain though we don't know much about
her prior to this moment but come on we
all knew that there's something awesome
about her and we didn't get let down not
even a single bit I gotta say I loved
how the entire scene was executed from
the build up to the actual flashy
entrances giland makes short work of the
kidnappers and the anime team really
made it a point to drive home how it's
just another day for her and at the end
of the day she makes a beautiful mess
out of it and these few seconds did so
much in showing us a lot about her
character and what she brings to the
table Elaine would prove to be a
valuable Ally and it's this first major
appearance that prepared us for that
thank you
since we talked about isakai how about
one that made the genre a household name
anicization Arc had its Grand Finale
last 2020 and what more could you ask
for than Kirito's glorious return after
being sidelined for an entire core he
finally made his return in a big way I
feel that the actual Awakening is good
and so was his appearance in the after
Story in space I was seriously given
though some considering but how can you
say no to how he saved Alice and the
dragons all while standing like a boss
ready to take on the final boss of the
Ark it's one of the more hype moments in
the second part of analystization's War
of Underworld maybe a tie or second only
to Kirito saving Arsenal in the form of
activating eugeo sword an episode ago
and while it may be purely coincidental
the way Kirito floated in the air there
really gave me flashbacks to Naruto
returning in Sage form don't you agree
that's the Kirito Sao fans have grown to
love confident badass and ready to take
on even the greatest challenges even
when the odds don't favor him and again
such a god-like opponent like subtilizer
he needed all the help he could get
Subaru has never looked as cool as he
did towards the final of re-zero season
two
immediately
it's like the perfect blow up moment for
Subaru he's had a lot of growing done
and through all the loops in his steady
determination he made his arrival at the
end of season two looking more like your
awesome heroic issakai protagonist this
moment just had everything you expected
from Subaru and more he already had a
lot of cool moments of leading the
charge under his belt and this adds more
to that ever growing resume Subaru's a
great character overall and this moment
I feel is the culmination of all the
hard work of all the crappies had to
endure and learn from and the Quantified
version of the bonds he had to forge
with everyone in the second season so
yeah in the end it's still Beatrice and
Amelia who did most of the heavy lifting
against the killer rabbits but it is
Subaru who's been leading the charge and
he's been doing it for quite some time
already you can't tell me that you
didn't at least feel a bit emotional
seeing him arrive in the nick of time
all while that emotional Epson was
playing in the media preparing to make a
Last Stand how about a villainous one to
continue the list
foreign
[Music]
the best villains are known to strike
when the heroes are most vulnerable and
that's just what agaza did when he made
his heart pounding entrance our hero
just had the fight of their lives
against enmu and then comes an even
stronger foe ready to pick up the pieces
whether it's the movie version or the TV
version both entrances do an excellent
job in giving the audience a huge swerve
just when you think the climax is over
it turns out it's just the beginning
akaza's first appearance is so on point
with it being slow dramatic and even
haunting you just knew that there was no
way the good guys were going to come out
of this one unscathed and yet rengoku
puts up a great fight giving us the true
climactic ending that people will always
remember seriously I mean just look
around you how many people remember the
end move fight over this spectacle one
which also serves as a great farewell
for a character we barely knew but have
also grown to like over the course of an
hour or just a couple of minutes
definitely a villain entrance done right
[Music]
one piece is the gift that keeps on
giving and this entry is definitely one
of those
oh
I've often featured one piece on this
channel I can't help it when it's one of
the most awesome battles Shonen out
there still going strong after Decades
of running heck I think that in a lot of
ways more than one piece has even
outshone the classic one thanks to
advancement in animation and adaptation
style and it's these advances that make
entrances like this just so awesome I
haven't featured Zorro a whole lot in
the numerous entries I put on for this
series but here he is deservingly so as
well as this was an entrance for the
ages he had his Shining Moments in
fights but has he had an entrance as
cool and as flashy as this one it's a
really awesome entrance and one that
I'll definitely remember for years to
come
come true
[Music]
if you like this video so far make sure
to leave a like and subscription while
you're at it it takes just a few seconds
and you'll be helping out the channel a
lot thank you black clove ended in a
Victorious Fanfare as an anime and along
the way it brought us even more cool
entrances
what I really like about the black balls
is that they have a bond that's
practically familiar these guys may be
rough around the edges and bicker with
one another but when push comes to shove
you bet they still stick to each other
through till The Bitter End we have the
fin rail scene to look back on but take
a step further and have one of them be a
wanted individual on the verge of
execution you can still count on Yami
and the Gang to come busting in giving
zero damn and what people think of the
group this is one of the most explosive
and loudest entrances in the show and it
really shows the group's philosophy as a
whole doesn't matter if you're Royal or
not these badass Crews stick by one of
their own it's a really impactful moment
and one that helps Define this Arc it
also drives home what the black balls
are really all about
attack on Ty is about to reach its Grand
conclusion and I'd like to take this
time to look back at one of the best
moments from a recent season
there are so many things to like about
Attack on Titan Seasons from the
successful shift and role reversals to
the continued fights and spine chilling
moments few moments are as powerful as
the rumbling but we're not going to be
talking about that right now compared to
the rumbling this one was way more
sudden more Dynamic more forceful in
terms of impact and it's something I
appreciate a lot more thanks to the
build up can I just say how much I love
the whole talk you had with Reiner all
the things he'd been through had been
enough to have him reach the boiling
point and he comes out with probably the
most explosive transformation he's done
so far it all happened in a snap and in
perfect timing and that shot of Aaron's
Titan rising up and roaring is one of
the most iconic things I can see from
this season
thank you
one long-running series that did end was
Jojo and with its Stone ocean came a
nostalgic return
foreign
well he's back for good and we see him
coming at the nick of time saving Jolene
when the going got really tough as
someone who likes Jojo I can't
appreciate this moment enough the timing
and the atmosphere it's just perfect for
it the certain entry of the time
stopping power the iconic music and an
awesome punch heard around the world
such a great entrance and the best way
to welcome back an all-time fan favorite
character and it comes with another easy
win under his belt and a statement made
that's the jotara that we know and loved
and I can't think of a better way to
reintroduce him formally than this Stone
ocean has more surprises on the way so
if you're on the lookout for them why
not head to Netflix and watch the
conclusion of an Epic Journey
foreign
[Music]
bleach made his comeback and it's one of
the best returns in Shonen anime history
[Music]
foreign
blood War that made it a serious
Contender for the best anime of its
season compared to continuations or
reboots like Shaman King bleach just
blows everything out of the water due to
its now streamlined storytelling various
additions that enhance the Manga version
and now it's chock full of moments to
remember Beach's latest season has no
shortage of dynamic entrances and a lot
of it courtesy of the main character
himself Ichigo has made a living out of
great entrances in the span of a core
but my favorite one by far is his entry
into Soul Society it's just an entrance
that gives me a mixture of emotions on
one hand it's a long time coming as he'd
spent episodes on end trying to break
out of the jail and him just one shot in
the stern Ritter was hype on the other
hand he arrived at a devastated Soul
Society was the recipient of arousing
yet somber biakuya speech and quickly
got to work going after yuha almost
immediately he almost didn't say
anything here but you can just feel the
emotions about to overflow in him
there's that lucky name that you haven't
seen in a while and this is where Ichigo
is at his most dangerous such a powerful
sequence of events and it's only the
first encounter with the Quincy's mind
you can't wait for the next part of this
Arc
to finish off with what people can say
to be bleacher's spiritual successor Jiu
Jitsu Kaizen
shows like bleach open up the path for
titles like Jiu Jitsu Kaizen to walk and
Jiu Jitsu Kaizen gladly took that chance
and carved a name for itself in the
history of Shonen anime Jiu-Jitsu Kaizen
may not have reached the incredible
highs that bleach and Demon Slayer had
in terms of popularity but don't call it
a slouch in the field of Animation
creating a remarkable memory after
another the fights they're just simply
on point if there's any doubt as to what
mappa can do for Shonen fight scenes Jiu
Jitsu Kaizen should put all of that to
rest the Epic fights are everywhere and
we're only a little over halfway done
through the season at this point when
Gojo makes his epic entrance at the
climax of The Ark he unleashes Hollow
purple to finish the job that aoi and
Yuji started it's an entrance to an
appearance that lasts as quickly as it
started but I don't think we've seen
Gojo any cooler than he was in those few
seconds it helps that we're still
feeding the adrenaline rush from one of
the best fights in the series only for
Gojo's appearance to give it a
much-needed Crescendo the good news
we've still got a lot more Jiu Jitsu
Kaizen coming our way so stay tuned for
the next season and the numerous epic
moments that we've got coming ahead
and that's a wrap thanks for watching
the video I hope you enjoyed it if you
want more the Channel's always open for
browsing some videos and you can follow
Vinnie tube on social media I really
appreciate you staying to the end and
I'll see you on the next video